Only 3 teams,
I'm getting older for a moment
.
Come out
, prepare for it,
but I have a proposal
.
Oh, it's the batter, it's the road Go
ahead
[music] I
chose to use my power in vain
Yeah yeah yeah I didn't hear me say
no
Did you know that Pooh was going to be like this?
I'm going to squeeze it I thought that's [ __ ]
so I gathered my friends I put you guys in
this bag
in turn and carried it
I'll let you pass the 6th exam so please lend me your strength  No,
I didn't expect the party that you guys met in that field.
It
looks like you're carrying a rather heavy bag, so
take them out of your bag during the break time after the 9th exam and let's talk about
it.
Don't you realize you're doing that?